derniers préparatifs avant une sortie
devenu exceptionnel que chercher mon
petit pré désinfectant elsa est sur le
point de quitter son domicile
chose qu'elle ne s'était plus permis
depuis une semaine avant de partir
la jeune femme n'oublie pas le désormais
précieux sésame l'attestation de
déplacement option quatre déplacements
pour motif familial un période pour
assistance aux personnes vulnérables aux
gardes d'enfants et entre parenthèses
j'ai rajouté don de sang après quelques
jours de confinement pour elsa
l'étonnement est presque à chaque coin
de rue notamment à la vue de ce parc
aujourd'hui désertés donc là on passe un
joli parc juste à côté de chez moi et
[Musique]
normalement c'est rempli d'enfants de
parents et là il y avait deux personnes
personnes
juste quelques petites quelques petites
abeilles peut-être un peu lunaire même
étonnement devant un supermarché où elle
constate qu'on ne peut désormais plus
entrer sans patienter un peu je
m'aperçois que maintenant les gens font
la queue devant les supermarchés
l'associé leurs prévisions s'est un peu
fait peur
henrotin une trentaine de minutes plus
tard elle a retrouvé son amie julie
toutes deux se sont donné rendez vous
pour donner leur sang
l'occasion de se revoir mais de loin
mais d'autres ont eu la même idée et en
raison d'une forte affluence
impossible d'entrer sans s'inscrire sur
une liste d'attentes
il faut régulièrement soit appelée
soit-elle temps d'aller sur le site de
l'uefa
les prend tout simplement rendez vous en
ligne pour pouvoir venir donner votre
sang dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
l'établissement français du sang appelle
à continuer de se rendre dans les
centres de collecte pour un don de sang
plus que jamais vitale pour les patients